hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
um june 28th
2020 what's going on how are you
how you doing how how's how is your life
going
um mine ain't going so good today
jesus christ you know over the last i
don't know three months
i knew i was putting on weight and i
kept saying step on the scale
to see where you're at and i'm like i
don't want to see that number
the dumb thing that's the stupidest
thing you can do when i knew
it i knew it was a dumb thing to do
you know and i'd go on a hike here or
i'd go do a little [ __ ]
take a walk some stairs there but every
day
i was stuffing my fat freckled face i
stepped on the [ __ ] scale
189 and that's only because i ate a
cheeseburger
that just sat in my stomach like lead at
like 3
30 the day before and i hadn't eaten in
like 12 hours so i was probably like a
buck 91.
oh my god what am i doing
so my fighting weight is 171 so i i got
like 20 pounds i got to lose
um the people around me aren't helping
me
you're going really you know you look
fine to me you look great
it's like stop saying that
say it again i'll take my shirt off and
then you [ __ ] say it
say that again with the [ __ ]
believable look on your face
so um i'm back on it i'm weighing myself
every day and i'm going to get back down
to 171 where i need to be
um it's always fun the first day when
you eat well
and you work out you know because you
immediately dropped like a pound or two
which is what happened this morning i
might have just been dehydrated or
whatever
but uh so it was 187 when i got on the
scale but now
now after the first day then i feel like
you bar
your body's just like oh this is what
we're doing
let's [ __ ] pump the brakes here let's
put on the parking brake for the
for the last [ __ ] whatever 16
17 pounds so um
yeah so i got to do this the right way i
gotta see now i got to make sure that as
i'm dropping it it's
fat and not muscle because then i'll get
down to 171
you know and that's when you have the
e.t body you know what i mean your arms
are all skinny your legs are skinny then
you have that little pot
so i got to make sure i uh i have the um
you know get plenty of protein and all
that type of stuff which i know what i
got to do but i'm i'm
i was pretty upset with myself yesterday
and on a low level upset with my wife
because she i kept saying like am i is
it me am i a fat bastard when i wasn't
weighing myself because
rather than just going in and she'd be
like bill you look great you look fine
it's like
it's like that how does that help me
[Music]
if your wife says to you
you know you're looking a little chunky
there
you're a little chunky monkey there that
what's that the ice cream you've been
eating you're looking like what the [ __ ]
you're eating i don't eat that [ __ ] by
the way
i'm not into that one with the [ __ ]
bananas in it i i like the [ __ ] the
old school ice cream
you know where it was just sugar
cream whatever the [ __ ] is in it and ice
ice cream maybe some chocolate chips
maybe a little pistachio
you know what i mean before they came
over this ice cream where you [ __ ]
empty the cupboard and throw it in there
like [ __ ] potato chips and bananas
and uh i don't know what else [ __ ]
detergent tablets
um coffee i guess coffee's been around
for a while oh i'm just a [ __ ]
why can't things be the way they always
were
um yeah so that is uh that's where i'm
at
and um i've just been thinking in my
head
of the four kings documentary that i
watched where everybody on that thing
was roughly my height
maybe a little shorter except for thomas
hearns and they were all like a buck 55
156 now obviously that's
a boxer so i got to feel like if i get
down to like you know
anywhere between 165 170 i should be
good
um so rather than starving myself
i'm just going to be eating right and
going for walks
walks of the [ __ ] when you get older
they don't [ __ ] hurt your knees
you do it at night you know
um but speaking of which but i'll be
doing a lot of cardio the next three
nights because i am at the comedy store
running my hour hour and 10 minutes
um because i got my first indoor road
gig in las vegas it's my first
indoor road gig since the all of this
[ __ ] started
so um very excited
and uh slash nervous you know what i
mean you want to do a good job you don't
want to show up
and just phone it in or whatever
you know um
so you know i was driving around town
and i saw this [ __ ]
um i saw this uh
this billboard for that new britney
spears
documentary and it was just like
heartbreaking devastating eye-opening
toxic and i was just sitting there going
like only in this [ __ ] country could
a blonde white woman
sell out arenas make millions of dollars
and then [ __ ] they come back around
it's like oh my god
what did they do to her
[Music]
now i'm not saying that she wasn't
horribly misguided
i'm not saying that you know i don't i
don't even know the [ __ ] story
this to me always comes down to that bit
i used to do
the way they told the story of that
woman serial killer
versus a charlie manson or a [ __ ]
jeffrey dahmer where it's just like
they're made out to be
lunatic [ __ ] mad men
but the woman serial killer
went out and they they they blamed
guys
well if the guys didn't do this to her
then she wouldn't have been murdering
those guys
okay all right well [ __ ] was done to me
when i was a kid
i didn't go out and then do it to other
people
right that doesn't make is am i
i don't know am i thinking crazy here
if you were a kid and somebody tortured
you somehow then you grow up and you
just start torturing people because you
were tortured
and then what you're you're still a
victim
because evidently that's what america
american cinema wants you to believe
um no it's just
it's very interesting thing how some
people get treated versus how other
people get treated like let's talk about
formula one here
or actually watch the race because
everybody's like bill you got to come
back to f1 you got to come back to f1
max verstappen is is competitive he's
he's ahead in the point so i sit down
and watch the race yesterday
and uh verstappen takes the lead into
the first turn
lewis hamilton is in second place the
most exciting
possible situation in in formula one
max verstappen first place after the
first turn
lewis hamilton in second place because
now you're gonna get to see some racing
okay but you know max i think wired a
wire
i watched three quarter of the race
before i had to go to a kid birthday
party
um oh dude i mean i literally had to
break out the hawaiian shirt like that's
that's
i am in hawaiian button-down shirt
i don't think they make hawaiian
pullovers hawaiian shirt shape
i took i showed up total [ __ ]
dad outfit i had hawaiian shirt
i had white linen pants and i had a pair
of crocs
on with socks that's right old freckles
has crocs
i didn't want him my wife kept
asking me do you want a pair of these
and i was like no i
no i do not i do not then the kids
she got a pair and then the kids got a
pair and then a friend of our family got
a pair and i kept saying i don't want
him
you know no means no i don't want
crocs i'm good thank you thank you for
asking 40 times
father's day comes along guess what he
gets a pair of crocs
oh the exact thing i said i didn't want
to
want oh no you shouldn't have no
literally
you shouldn't have so um i got a pair of
those plastic [ __ ] boats that will
exist a thousand years after i'm dead
that's all i think about when i wear
them
i'm like is it plastic should be like a
family heirloom now
just hand down generation to generation
this spatula has been in our family for
800 years
making scrambled eggs back when there
was chickens
um so i got a pair of them
i got to say they're pretty comfortable
they're pretty comfortable it definitely
looks like you know
i don't know what i feel like when i
wear him you immediately feel like a
guru
like you're just up there just talking
some [ __ ]
um oh my god speaking of that
should i talk about this now or get back
to the f1 [ __ ]
wait a second what is this [ __ ] guy's
name
michael
oh man i forget the guy's [ __ ] name
god damn it
i was watching this thing on uh you know
my wife likes watching these [ __ ]
dateline nbc shows i i really think snl
did a sketch about how women like to
watch like these murder shows right
and she explained it to me she goes well
you know as a woman you know you feel
like you're not as strong so you you try
to watch me
try to figure out what you would do in
that situation and i'm like all right
that was a good answer i don't know if i
believe it but you know it's a good
answer
um so
she put on dateline nbc and this show
was funny she ended up falling asleep
and i actually i watched it to the end
because this guy was such a piece of
[ __ ] i had to see him get caught
this guy went to like
i don't know usc or ucla
and i guess was a really good doctor and
he decided to
uh open a uh one of those nose ears and
throat
one of those guys doctors and he picked
a town in indiana that has a bunch of
factories with
horrible pollution
um i was like all right you know this
guy location location location and he
just made like
all of this money and he was like flying
around in private jets and had a yacht
and all this and i'm thinking like
wait this guy's doing this off of being
a you know
nose ear nose ear and throat doctor
that's what it is
the [ __ ] he making all of this money
and then he had all his state-of-the-art
equipment and he was like
doing like like 30 something surgeries a
week it was [ __ ] insane
and what he was doing was if you just
came in
it didn't matter what your [ __ ]
problem was he just said you needed
sinus surgery
and he would just go in there and maybe
he would do something maybe he wouldn't
he would just fiddle around
inside your nose you'd be done in a half
an hour he'd have no follow-up and he'd
give you a little saline solution and
that was it
and one woman came in she clearly had
throat cancer
and he ignored it and i mean
she was a heavy smoker so that was on
her but like
he could have helped her be diagnosed
early on which led to this
you know horrible quality of life or
whatever another
one was this little girl who had like
ended up having a brain tumor but
because this [ __ ] [ __ ] went in
there and did
surgery all this scar tissue which i
don't understand why they can't get
through it
they could only get 10 of it fortunately
the kid lived
by the end of it i'm like they should
[ __ ] hang this guy by his [ __ ]
toes
blah blah blah blah so he goes on
vacation abandons his wife
and just [ __ ] you know is a fugitive
right they end up catching the [ __ ]
guy like five years later
he has all of these lawsuits he's been
stripped of his uh
medical license and all of that [ __ ] and
in the end of all of this okay
guess what this guy gets the first thing
they were gonna give him two years
two years it's just that classic [ __ ]
thing
where you know white-collar crime
it's [ __ ] ridiculous so
the doctor the lawyer whatever they end
up getting this guy and then i think he
ended up getting like seven years
or he did like seven years or something
like that and now he's out
now he's trying to start this yoga thing
right he's gonna be a yoga instructor
and he's such a lunatic he's like you
know
people talk yoga about spirituality and
all that who's kid who it's not about
that
it's about looking hot so you can get
some [ __ ] ass i mean that's basically
that's what he reduced yoga to
um and he still goes around calling
himself a doctor it was so [ __ ]
upsetting i actually looked up the bet
that some of the victims because i was
going to try to go out there and do a
benefit for him because one of them the
mother of the kid
was going ah you know the key wiped out
my
savings and now this guy he's just like
down in miami doing like [ __ ] yoga
it's a whole thing it's just
it was really up it was just wasn't it
wasn't satisfying on any level
other than the fact they stopped him
from doing that
um
and the only time the guy owned up to
you know i heard a lot of people the
only time he owned up to it was when he
was staring you know at a jail sentence
so he just said the things that they
knew he wanted them to say
um just a complete narcissist [ __ ]
sociopath and all of that [ __ ] which is
uh
the problem with those types of people
is you're never going to get
satisfaction you're never going to get
closure
you just have to walk away from them
that's kind of what it is but a guy like
that they should have walked away as
they closed the [ __ ] jail cells like
i should have gone to jail for [ __ ]
life
he should have got like two life
sentences for what the [ __ ] he did
to sit there and and
be performing surgery on people that
don't even need surgery or it's not the
proper surgery i mean
but you know you get caught with like uh
you know a [ __ ]
a [ __ ] kilo of cocaine you're going
to jail for [ __ ] life
and this [ __ ] guy is sitting there
rooting around at people's [ __ ] noses
right i mean there's a a kid with the
tumor that they could have got out and
now they can't because of what the [ __ ]
you did
that's it you're done you don't get to
go to miami and do [ __ ] yoga
that's [ __ ] annoying it's really
annoying all right let's get back to
something a little more fun annoying
let's talk f1
so i'm watching the race right and then
i have to go to the kid birthday party
uh by the way i have the same colored
crocs as my son so it was kind of cute
we both were wearing blue and white so
i'm not gonna you know
and then my daughter was also wearing
blue and white and it just kind of all
came together by accident
i think my wife was dressing the kids
the same way
and then i just went with my fat clothes
that just happened to match them
and um i mean i'm telling you right now
isn't it if you're a dad you got to have
at least one hawaiian shirt in your
[ __ ] closet for those
after the holidays as you start to walk
it off
you know you got to start dressing like
robin williams rest his soul
um so i'm watching the the highlights
because i had to watch the highlights to
see the end of the race i thought i
taped it and i didn't
and um they're screaming about matt for
stop
max verstappen gonna win the race but
they're also screaming about lewis
hamilton
because it's not a race unless you're
talking about the [ __ ] diva
right and lewis hamilton's getting new
tires
he's going for the fastest lap
the [ __ ] announcer is like and max
verstappen wins
25 points to leader f1 and lewis
hamilton
also gets the fastest lap
what would they be doing if they weren't
blowing that guy even if he doesn't win
he got an extra point
it's just fun i remember like that's my
number one [ __ ] problem
i have the same problem i have with f1 i
have with the [ __ ] nba
is is it's just like i don't know
if somebody wins they're the [ __ ]
winner talk about them so like a long
time ago when the red sox [ __ ] won a
world series
espn red sox win the world safe did i do
the whole [ __ ] thing and then they go
reaction in the bronx like
why do we have to sit here and listen to
that [ __ ] they didn't win they're not
champions
why are you talking about them why are
you talking about lewis hamilton he
didn't [ __ ] win
he is not the leader right now drives me
up
the [ __ ] wall i remember a couple
years ago when i was when i when i was
starting to be like you know what
[ __ ] formula one i'm not watching this
[ __ ] anymore this is a lewis hamilton
reality show
i remember he had a shitty qualifying
something happened to his car and god
forbid he was in like
third or fourth position and he pulls
into the garage
and he just sat in his car with his head
down with his hand
helmet on and they just sat there
talking about how upset he was
they were like oh oh you know [ __ ] uh
whoever
whoever the [ __ ] got the uh you know
daniel ricardo gets to pull
but look how upset lewis he's devastated
oh my god his heart breaks he just wants
to win
dude he drives for mercedes i'm not
saying he's not the best driver
okay but there's a bunch of drivers that
would be beating his ass every [ __ ]
week if he didn't drive for [ __ ]
mercedes and had a different [ __ ] car
all right max verstappen won the race
shut the [ __ ] up about this [ __ ] jerk
off who gets one goddamn
point and i shouldn't even be upset with
him because he's not the one doing it so
my apology to lewis hamilton i should
have said that
the [ __ ] jerk off who was saying that
is the jerk off
but i guess they added that to make it
like an
exciting thing it's sort of like the
three-pointer it's like the technical
foul shot of formula one where you get
an extra point
that could add up i could pay dividends
i can't believe it the best driver who
drives for the team with the most money
and the best equipment just had the
fastest lap
that's just as exciting as the person
with a lesser team
with lesser equipment that actually beat
this diva [ __ ]
equal level of excitement
that's what's wrong with sports the
bottom line is they know that lewis
hamilton puts
asses in the seats and he is their
[ __ ] show pony right now
so no matter what happens win or lose
you know that was like back in the day
when the red sox were [ __ ] going all
right so i guess you got to spend 200
million dollars and buy up the league to
win it
to stop the a5 we'll do it again and
then we [ __ ] do it like
reaction in the bronx
sorry boston new york's just a bigger tv
market
we have to keep this hatfield and mccoy
thing let me guess were they
not happy in the bronx
i mean the only story there would be
actually be if they were kind of like
okay with it slash happy
that would actually maybe be an
interesting story but if they're not
happy with it
and they're now going to try to do
things to their team to try and beat us
the next year is
kind of exactly what you'd think they
would be doing
ah [ __ ] out of breath after that one
um i also watched um i got caught up
here um
you know i haven't been watching a lot
of racing because i've been too busy
eating
oh god it's actually it was getting to
the point where
it i wasn't making effort noises
to put on my socks but there was there
was definitely
an effort being made um
yeah when you got to start putting your
leg up onto something
to get your socks on like trying to
figure out a different way
to fold yourself in half i wanted people
whose psoas is so flexible
they can actually get way fatter because
when they get to that point
where they can't go forward they can
actually go the other way bend over
backwards and then put it on
um
just looking at my notes from last night
because i don't have a lot of time today
i wanted to
i have
i have f1 max verstappen lewis hamilton
gets fastest lap
then i got a couple other topics and
then i got billy fat cakes
and you know what i went to this that
kid birthday party yesterday and i
walked in that was like i'm not having
any cake i'm not having any of this
stuff
i had some vegetables with
uh like half a spoon of guacamole
and waters that's all i had the three
hours that i was there
and um
you know it was you know it was actually
cool was i went there and
um my daughter really likes to play
catch now
which was fun and then a couple of the
other kids came over
they also wanted to play catch and stuff
like that so it's cool that
kids still want to do stuff like that so
i was kind of having a
uh i was kind of having a blast doing
that and oh my god dude these kids are
so freaking smart now
so i was playing catch with my daughter
with this little uh
you know sort of squishy ball
and then this kid comes over it's his
ball
and he's all upset that we're playing
catch with it i'm like what's the matter
he goes that's not a
ball that's a planet and i was like what
because it's not a ball it's a planet
and he goes look
and on the side of the ball uranus was
was written on it and i was like oh my
god and i had tried to explain it to my
my daughter she's going dad it's a ball
and i'm like well i mean
it is a ball but it says uranus on it
now so now it's like a planet
and i go over there i go there's a ball
that one right there is just a ball it
was actually a little ball that was
supposed to be like a bowling ball
but it was like the size of like a i
don't know like a big tennis ball
so she's all like no i want to play with
the other one
and the other kid's going it's not a
it's not a ball it's a planet it became
like this
this thing you know and uh then we
finally we all we all got past it
because at some point the really smart
kid
just goes all right he goes it's a ball
not a planet he kind of saw that it was
upsetting
the kid was like so smart
it was ridiculous he came over he was a
hundred percent right
he argued his position and then when he
realized it was upsetting people
he understood that it wasn't worth it
this this was this kid's four-year-old
birthday party
i was like i don't know what that kid's
gonna do in life but he's gonna be good
at it
so then anyway
i was playing with the other kids or
whatever and you know they're at this
great edge they're all about
like in the the parent circle that i'm
in everybody all the kids are like three
and four years old and the kids are
hilarious
so at every party there's always like
the one the kid that's just grabbing
toys so this one kid was she was just
grabbing the toys you know they don't
[ __ ] know they don't know right
it's just uh an aggressive personality
more aggressive personality
who doesn't know social rules yet right
so
this kid does it a couple times i always
just go hey you know
you got to ask first get asked first
right
so um
the kid does it again takes this little
puppet away from this other kid
i finally just said hey give that back
okay you can't go around taking clothes
you can't go around taking
uh the puppet away from uh
toys away from the other kids and the
kid
that got the puppet taken away from her
when i go you
shouldn't be take don't take toys away
from other kids
the other kid who got the toy taken away
turned around looked at me and said
i know you're not talking to me
and i was just like oh [ __ ] i wasn't
i was on your side
and then the other kid who was taking
the toys was just staring daggers at me
like you don't tell me what to do look
like who the [ __ ] are you would be
telling me what to do
so i'm trying to [ __ ] hold my
stairway i looked away like three times
because i didn't know what to do it's
like i don't get into a hostile
situation with you but i also
you kind of have to understand you can't
be doing this you know
there was a lot of [ __ ] going on at that
party yesterday but it was a lot of fun
and uh the kids were awesome but i'll
tell you right now that kid that was
taking the toys the look that she was
giving me
uh that is a that is a ice hockey teen
captain if i ever saw one
she had [ __ ] uh mark messier
we will win against new jersey look on
her face
um was not appreciating
a bald fat orange man telling her what
she can and can't do i can tell you that
um all right so anyway i
watched uh mark marquez win his first
race since he came back from the uh
broken um uh
humorous he's another guy it's funny i
actually root against him just because
you know
i'm not gonna just take up a new sport
and root for lewis hamilton the guy's
the best driver there is so
you know am i gonna jump on the
bandwagon like a [ __ ] free agent i'm
not doing that so i gotta root against
these guys
so i root against mark marquez but not
in like a uh you know
but motogp is fun because
there's actually like passing and that
type of stuff and
it's been like real competitive you know
i got a few races behind so
uh i am excited for that now i feel bad
i probably went too [ __ ] hard on
the announcers on f1 but
it's just like can you give max
verstappen his [ __ ] do
jesus christ you see he just got 25
points you're screaming just as loud for
a guy who got one extra point
that drives for the team that has the
most [ __ ] money oh gee he just got a
new set of tires really did he you know
and on a mercedes did he get the fastest
lap holy [ __ ]
who would have thunk it um
all right i went to the sun's game
game three
against the clippers um
sort of an ugly game like the uh the
sun's
only uh shot like 40 percent for the
game
and um but the clippers in the first
half were not
shooting much better but then they went
on a run in the second half the place
was going nuts so it was a
really fun game to go to and
um you know but it was that typical
nba experience where just every time
there was a stoppage of play
there was some sort of activity the
activity that they had you
watch and i really felt that it took
away from the drama of the game
like we were never solidified as a crowd
because what happens with the crowd is
they're watching something
and they're all taking the same
emotional ride
all right and everybody has a different
reaction to it
but overall there becomes a vibe in the
crowd
and everybody's on the edge of their
seat but like
they were like these really dramatic
moments that were happening like oh the
clippers gonna pull away they're down
two games
to none they need such an important game
for them to win
and then all of a sudden you're just
looking at the jumbotron
watching people uh lip sync journey
don't stop believing
or you know find let's see who's the
best [ __ ] dancer
just people making absolute fools of
themselves
to get on the [ __ ] jumbotron and uh
then it's like what the [ __ ] is is that
really a guy
like twerking still and his kids are
there i think that's a dad
and i'm processing that and then you
just say
you know that's horn and then i was oh
wait i'm at a playoff game
it's just really weird um
but i will say that they do a really
good job if you're watching it at home
that you can't hear all the [ __ ] that's
going on but it was like
i heard something on the internet
describe it it was like you were at a
chuck e cheese birthday party
while there was a a uh playoff game
going on and it's really insulting to
the fans
which is i was like well i can't say it
any better than that some guy on reddit
because i actually googled to see like
am i am i just being a grumpy old man am
i the only guy that feels like
they should tone it down a little bit um
but uh yeah it's really i don't know
it's weird so anyway i saw that game and
then i watched
i was in a cigar bar with my wife who
actually got into the game i was
watching game four
sons clippers and um we actually had to
go and she got so into it
she goes well we can't leave now i was
like oh my god
oh my god it almost took me 20 years i'm
making her a sports fan she's hanging in
a cigar bar
this is [ __ ] great uh
yeah we but we ended up having to leave
because our babysitter you know had to
go so we ended up having to get out of
there but uh
i watched most of that game and i was
watching the first half going like am i
out of my [ __ ] mind why didn't i just
bet the suns
i should have buried the sun say shot 40
percent
they're gonna blow them out and the
second i texted that to versi
all of a sudden the clippers closed it
down to like you know
actually took the lead at one point i
think or tied it up and i had to leave
right during that uh the ugliest part of
the game where they there was like 14
possessions between the two teams and
nobody scored any points
um it's like there was a [ __ ] lid on
the bucket uh but anyway we're just
gonna talk sports today
the montreal canadiens are in the finals
against your
tampa bay lightning looking to go back
to back the first time since the
pittsburgh penguins in 2016.
was it 2015 2016
or 2015 2016. then it was the capitals
then it was the blues
and then it was the uh lightning
so as a hab hater
um first of all i got to say
congratulations to the montreal
canadiens
uh they're just playing like they're
playing such good hockey i can't even
get mad at them
they're actually fun to watch um
as a bruins fan who took all kinds of
[ __ ]
from those [ __ ] you know
pseudo-frenchies up there
for the first i don't know how many
years of my life
um
i got to be honest with you i was hoping
that the islanders were going to win
because i feel like they're a better
matchup with the canadians
where the canadians have jet they keep
playing
teams like tampa like these offensive
you know juggernauts they got you know
an ability to score and all of that [ __ ]
and they know how to shut down
scoring teams and the islanders were
built the same way as the canadians
and uh they just ended up finally
running into a team
that they couldn't stop so they weren't
quite as good but i thought it was going
to be way more interesting to try
and to watch the canadians kind of play
a version of themselves
two you know four checking teams okay
you're going to take away our top two
lines we're going to take away your top
two lines you got a hot goaltender so do
we
um kind of see boxer against boxer where
i feel like the canadians it's been you
know boxer versus brawler
and uh that's what i feel like it's
gonna be here again and i hate to say
this but i think the canadians not only
gonna win i think they're gonna win in
six
um i just
you know defense wins championships and
nobody's doing it better than the
canadians
and i'm just gonna say it was so much
fun to watch the canadians go through
this 28-year drought
and but uh i'm not gonna lie if i had to
put my money down that's what i think is
going to happen
now if you're a tampa bay lightning fan
you have to understand that i have been
wrong
about everything and also know that i'm
not deliberately picking the canadians
just to try and jinx them i'm not
it's just like this is like this this
the vancouver um vancouver i keep
calling vancouver
the vegas knights presented the exact
same problem
that tampa presents the exact same that
that toronto presented
a high scoring you know offensive power
uh i don't know how high scoring of
vegas was but
um they know how to they know how to
shut down a team like this
and what i have found is that the
offensive
power doesn't know how to
um i guess do to the other team what
they're doing
what's being done to them it's weird
but that's how it is so we shall see
that's my prediction
uh canadians in six oh god that
[ __ ] kills me to say that [ __ ]
kills me to say that
uh it's depressing what's a good
cure for depressing uh depression oh
let's read out loud
this is always good to make you laugh
laughing's good for the soul all right
butcher box everybody
are you itching for the outdoors it's
grilling season baby
get ready it's grilling season yeah baby
get ready for that summer cookout you
know what will happen so just prepare
for it not everyone has convenient
access to high quality meat luckily
today's sponsor butcher box believes
everyone deserves high quality humanely
sourced meat
butcher box could be couldn't be easier
just sign up
select your box and ship it right over
to uh ship it right to your door every
month
and new members will get free bacon for
life when they sign up who does
who does not love free baking every
month butcher buck ships a curated
selection of high quality meat
right to my home you know stockpiling
some of it for the next [ __ ] pandemic
got to get yourself a meat freezer
that's a weird thing to buy when you're
married
big meat freezer what is that for
relax it's just to feed the family okay
especially if they watch like dateline
murder shows every [ __ ] night
all right every month butcher buck ships
a curated selection of high quality meat
right to my home
all meat is free of antibiotics and
added hormones can't put a price on that
each box has 9 to 11 pounds of meat
ladies
each enough for 24-hour individual meals
24 individual meals not 24 hour pack
fresh shipped frozen vacuum sealed so it
stays that way butcher box is a
no-brainer
options like 100 grass-fed
grass-finished uh
grass-fed and finish b free range or
organic chicken look at him go heritage
breeds
pork my favorite and wild caught alaskan
salmon you don't know what they're gonna
do
and sugar slash nitrate-free bacon
that's the way meat should be all right
making meat great again and they even
have free shipping nationwide except for
alaskan
alaska and uh hawaii just go to
butcherbox.com
that's a package of free bacon in every
every box for the life of your
subscription
when you go to butcherbox.com
oh look who it is everybody
it's helix helix not being able to sleep
because of today's politics
pandemics your love life any other drama
you talk about in your show
uh yeah i don't want to get into the
drama i couldn't sleep
uh no self-worth
uh helix sleep has a quiz that takes
just two minutes to complete and matches
your body type and sleep preference to
the perfect mattress for you
why would you buy him why would you buy
a mattress made from someone else
with helix alex you're getting a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you
sleep everybody's unique and special and
helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot gross
and even a helix plus mattress for plus
size forks get over here big boy
don't you lay down on that one it feels
great doesn't it like you're floating in
the ocean
it's been awesome getting messages from
so many of you
who also found the helix mattress of
your dreams
so if you're looking for him it's got to
be helix helix that sounds like hell
this is heaven helix healing
healing helix so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress that you
were matched to and the mattress comes
right to your door shipped for free
you don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again helix
is awesome but you don't need to take my
word for it
[Music]
was awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick for 2020
and by gq and wired magazine just go to
helix sleep.com
h-e-l-i-x take their two-minute sleep
quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10-year warranty
and you get to try it out for a hundred
nights gross risk-free they'll even pick
it up for you if you don't love it
yeah but you will helix is offering up
to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows
for our listeners um and
at helix sleep.com slash bur
okay last one policy
genius you know the word genius gets
thrown around a lot these days okay
but when it comes to policy genius it's
not an overshoot
it's not an overstep it's not an
overshare it's not an over something
summer's here and the days are getting
longer no they're not we're on the other
side june 21st is the longest day now
we're on the other side but seven days
the other way
uh meaning you've got some extra time to
see if you're overpaying for home and
auto insurance as adults
summer fun includes saving money policy
genius is a free and easy way to check
if you could be saving cash on what
you're paying for home and auto
insurance
are your home and auto policies almost
up for a renewal
well let policy genius look for a lower
rate for you
policy genius makes it easy to compare
home and auto insurance in one place
they can help you find home and auto
coverage similar to what you have now
but at a lower price they save customers
an average of 1
250 american dollars per year
over what they were paying for their
home and auto insurance
1250 bucks it's not bad
uh then almost get you a [ __ ] laptop
uh their team will handle the paperwork
to set up your new pulse maybe an ipad
your new policy one and a half ipads
their
team will handle the paperwork to set up
your new policy or switch over your
current one
getting started is easy first head to
policygenius.com and answer a few quick
questions
about yourself and your property then
policy genius takes it from there
they'll compare rates from america's top
insurers from progressive to allstate to
find your lowest quotes
the policy genius team can look for ways
to save you more including building
oh sorry bundling your home and auto
insurance policies
if they find a better rate than what
you're paying now they'll switch you
over for free
their top-notch services earn policy
genius an excellent rating
on trustpilot head to policygenius.com
to get started right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
all right here we go oh look who it is
everybody it's it's
it's the listeners it's the listeners
and they got some questions for you
okay father's day gripe
hey there billy paste face
more like billy pastry face i would like
to vent about the
vast inequities i experienced between
mother's day for my wife and father's
day for me uh i knew this would get
people going
on mother's day my wife sleeps in mine
does too and eventually wakes up to me
handing her a cup of freshly brewed
coffee in bed
when she eventually gets up and walks
out of our bedroom she'll notice fresh
fresh flowers in her vase breakfast
prepared and a greeting card on the
kitchen counter dude you're crushing it
i cooked for her her mother and her
sister later that day
point is i worked my ass off throughout
that day to make these women feel
special
now my father's day experience she slept
in
i made my own coffee i fed myself nobody
planned any party or get together for us
dads in the family
no card no present dads like to fire up
the grills so i cooked for my family
that evening
and we watched the hawks beat the
choking sixers i like cooking so it's no
big deal but i just find it funny
that we have to shower women with the
tension and acknowledgement
but not but that is not returned to us
on our special day
i'm good to my wife and kids so every
day is father's day
the way i experience life uh
the whole holiday thing is [ __ ]
anyways look at that
he just in the end he's just like it's
all [ __ ] anyway
yeah dude it's it's i don't know i don't
know that that will ever happen
i was gonna say like you know at some
point they'll maybe realize
the only way they like realize that [ __ ]
is if you do what i did between mother's
day and father's day you got to keep
hammering them
that your day is going to be just as
special as their day so they don't
forget
you know because if you don't it's going
to be it's going to be
a 8 to noon thing and then that's going
to be over
through my father's day there was there
was a [ __ ]
uh event it was a birthday party for one
of her girlfriends that was planned on
father's day
so we had to go to that that was my
father's day i'm not saying it was a bad
event i love those people i love her
girlfriend they're all [ __ ] great
people but it's like i just don't see a
world where like
you know if i planned a birthday party
for like you know
one of my buddies and it landed on
mother's day it's like that's that is
being rescheduled without a [ __ ]
doubt without a doubt it's being
rescheduled
um i mean still a great party and
everything i'm just saying
um so anyway uh yeah that's just kind of
it's kind of how it is
um and we always do generally speaking
a great thing for them on mother's day
but i don't feel that it's necessarily
done
a hundred percent out of love it's also
done out of self-preservation
in fear because you know that if
they don't feel special
then you know you're gonna have to deal
with the emotional ramifications of that
for anywhere from three days to
um they might never get over it um
and it'll be something that they bring
up in arguments forever so
yeah uh preaching to the choir uh but
just know this
at the end of the day you're a man so
you won
okay you're not as complex as them so
you can actually
enjoy life and you can kind of sustain
a certain level of happiness and a
certain level of satisfaction
you know because you're too dumb to know
that you should be upset this is genius
to our stupidity they're too smart to be
happy
um that's my theory anyway i don't know
just theories anyway okay f1
all right all right billy runs with fire
in his pants i don't know what that
means
i have a simple message watch f1 you
[ __ ]
i know you enjoy motorsports and get
really excited whenever you mention f1
but you haven't talked about the recent
f1 races which spoilers
have been incredible france happened
this weekend and that was an incredibly
satisfying race
baku happened two weeks ago and that was
probably one of the best races of this
decade an instant classic [ __ ] i missed
i can go back and watch them on their
website
get this due to new regulations red bull
is leading the con
constructors championship and max
verstappen is leading the drivers
championship with lewis
hamilton close behind this is the season
we've been waiting for yes it is
shut the [ __ ] up about hockey and watch
this [ __ ] for ten dollars a month well
the thing about hockey
is every season is the [ __ ] season
you're waiting for it's hockey it's
[ __ ] great
um maybe f1 should run their [ __ ]
business a little more like the nhl does
um anyways for ten dollars a month on f1
tv pro this is not an ad
i tried to get into motogp but that
subscription is 40
a month not worth it but f1 is no no no
no no no no no no no no i draw the line
there
i draw the [ __ ] line there dude all
of that [ __ ] that you're talking about
the best
race i watched that race and i guarantee
you
there was three races last year dude the
mark marco
mark marquez versus uh andres davizioso
battles there was like there's been like
three or four of those races
where they passed each other three to
four times on the final [ __ ] lap
and and that happened like two or three
times a [ __ ] season
okay so i don't want to hear like oh my
god we finally had a [ __ ] exciting
[ __ ] race
and now this is better than motogp if
you want to see passing
in racing which to me is people jocking
for position
passing you know the whole [ __ ] thing
then then i would say motogp is where
it's at
it's still where it's at and unlike you
i watch both of them i don't watch one
race oh
[ __ ] dude it's too much [ __ ] money
yeah you do
you you pay your little ten dollars for
the the inferior [ __ ]
racing sport i'll stick with motogp
anyway the next two weeks have races in
austria
tune your fat head in and watch mercedes
struggle
i mean i might as well because you know
at some point they're just going to
throw money at the [ __ ] problem
somehow
and uh they'll be right back you know
where they usually are
look at this guy this guy's so beaten
down as a fan of f1
that he's excited that in june mercedes
and lewis hamilton aren't in first place
um i don't know hey by the way isn't me
or does sebastian vettel lose his
[ __ ]
whatever the front or airfoil is every
other race
he lost one of his front wings he's got
damage he has to go into the pits oh
it's a disaster
all right what what i should have said
oh here we go
number one hey billy casper tits i'm
loving the i'm loving the body shame
here people i'm doing it to myself i
need this
i have a story from childhood that has
stayed with me to this day and i wish i
had said something i was about 12 years
old
and was with my older brother and his
friends who were both in high school
we all went to the movies to see
something i don't remember what the move
i don't remember what movie because my
memory is blinded by
rage the rage of something that happened
at the theater
i got an icy frozen drink and some candy
before the movie
during the movie i finished the drink at
one point
and put the empty cup under my chair
until the end of the movie
my brother and his friends were sitting
to my right and a family
was to my left at the end of the movie i
stood up with my group and began to
shuffle out of the theater
i felt someone poked me in the back it
wasn't the kind of poke like excuse me
it was pretty hard
and i knew right away it was someone
being aggressive
it felt more like hey [ __ ] kind
of poking my shoulder
i turned around and saw it was the
father of the family who was sitting
next to me
he was holding the empty cup i had an
accident left under my chair oh what a
[ __ ]
this guy looked like if roger goodell
was an
impotent used car salesman he had cargo
shorts
white new balances accountant glasses
stupid colored golf
polo shirt and a clinging
oh clinging to scraps comb over
oh dude if if a man has a comb over
you've already won the exchange
he shoved the cup into my chest and said
here your mom isn't here to pick up
after you
i was a pretty polite kid and i always
tried to be respectful and clean up
after myself i had just forgotten about
the cup
simple mistake right i was so surprised
and slightly humiliated
that a stranger would do that especially
to a kid i just took the cup and walked
off
but to this day i really wish i had said
something like you know what
i'm going to let you hold on to that you
[ __ ] janet reno looking
cheese dick it would have been
satisfying to throw the cup right back
into his face too but at last i did
nothing i hope he has asked cancer at
the end
um well listen there's a lot of
victory in this the guy has a comb over
he's such a small person that he does
that to another
they does that to a kid that that's not
a happy guy
he was taking out um
the dissatisfaction he has in his own
life on you and that's what a lot of
people who do [ __ ] like that are doing
um but oh i mean i bet to this day
you still feel that poke in the back
like it just [ __ ] happened
if you're anything like me all right
number two hey billy rednuts
a few years ago i was at 7 11. there was
a homeless guy sitting outside
it was the middle of the winter and
freezing cold so i went inside got
myself a cup of coffee
and a cup of coffee with a homeless guy
i went out and handed it to him
i walked away feeling good about myself
for doing the right thing
just then the homeless guy yelled at me
what no sugar i was stunned and kept
walking i wish i said go [ __ ] yourself
you miserable [ __ ]
ah yeah i've had that happen to me
remember there was this guy just out of
his mind on something
and he was sitting near i was doing a
spot at stand-up new york and i put some
change into his cup
and i walked about five paces and i just
heard that the sound of change
being thrown down the sidewalk and he
just goes [ __ ]
i think he yelled [ __ ] you as he threw
the change
back at me but i was he was also you
know [ __ ] out of his mind on whatever
he was on so
it happens yeah what no sugar
yeah what no job
only people inside get sugar
become a productive member of society
then you get a little treat in your
coffee
all of that [ __ ] comes to you but at the
end of the day dude it's a chromeless
person
could be somebody with mental issues
because they've shut down all the nut
houses
and they have a hot cup of coffee in
their hand you don't want to stir them
up
you wait till you get in your car and
then roll down the passenger window as
you drive by
yell some [ __ ] but you're driving so
fast because you're a coward all you
hear is this
that's how it's that's how it's done all
right
oh god this person used a word i don't
even know how to say it
pronunciation here b-a-n-a-l
pronunciation
there we go let's all learn something
shall we
come on banel banel
but now the [ __ ] does it mean that
doesn't sound like something good
lacking
originality freshness or novelty trite
all right hello but now bill that's a
that's you know that's the most educated
way i've ever been called a hack
i don't disagree all right the past year
was my first year of college so during
the pandemic
my school had very strict rules about
how many people you can have in your
room
one night me and my two roommates
decided to play some beer pong
about five minutes into playing a campus
officer walks into our room without
knocking
whoa this [ __ ] cop walked in like he
was about to make a drug bust
instantly he starts to opening drawers
and cabinets
then he says open up the fridge buddy
i responded with do you have the right
to search my fridge the cop says are you
a first year law student or something
i still lay awake thinking about things
i could have responded with
no i'm not but you're definitely not you
[ __ ] ren you're not even a real cop
i should have said something are you a
first-year rent-a-cop or something
that's even better
thanks for the laugh bills hey dude
the next time somebody just comes
walking in like that you have every
right to say get you go
you can't say [ __ ] though cause then
they'll get you on that get back outside
and knock
or i'm gonna report you you can't just
walk in well
actually find out if they can or not
it's not too late to file a complaint
it's kind of a [ __ ] thing to do but
but who knows
i mean what if that was like uh you know
would he do that with women
i don't know that guy sounds like a
[ __ ] character in a comedy
and the whole crowd's rooting for you to
try and get him back somehow
all right um all right what do we got
here i gotta get on with the [ __ ] day
here
almost dropped the laptop there what i
shouldn't what i shouldn't have said oh
here we go we got a new one
this is that what you were just
listening to is what i should have said
if you have a situation where somebody
said something to you
and you didn't [ __ ] think of anything
to say until like a [ __ ] month later
those are the what i should have said i
unplugged my [ __ ] headphones here but
if you actually gave into your urge and
then you said it
and dealt with the ramifications that
becomes a what i shouldn't have said
all right dear billy boston
burns i've enjoyed
uh the what i should have said recently
and i thought i'd throw out a story of
something that maybe i shouldn't have
said uh this was around 15 years ago i
was in my early 20s and my girlfriend
had gotten vip concert tickets to see
christina aguilera
um every note let me show you every note
on the scale every other line uh the
kind you are beautiful
the kind where you can get to go
backstage and meet them all that
[ __ ] holy [ __ ]
at the time i was a major bob dylan fan
he just does one note he
still still am but i was a bit of an
[ __ ] about it back then total music
snob oh all right
and they should do a duet bob dylan and
christina aguilera
you know just two different minimalist
style versus over the top
as i was met and i was mad that i had to
go watch christina aguilera when
literally any one of my girlfriend's
mates would have generally enjoyed it
yeah but i'm [ __ ] around but she can
actually sing she doesn't have bad songs
they're pop songs before what they are
they're good right
um but no drag the reluctant boyfriend
along
that's female logic right
well yeah i mean that's kind of what
they do
what i thought you'd enjoy it it's like
do i bring you to a football game
uh so we're backstage after the show and
standing in a long line of people when
uh people that christina is walking
along
shaking hands and posing for photos with
her nose turned up and pulling this face
like she shouldn't have to breathe the
same air as these people
she gets to my girlfriend shakes her
hand and takes a photo
christina then holds her hand out to me
and quick as a flash i wave it off and
tell her that's okay i'm not a fan
oh my god dude you said that
to be fair christina to christina
she couldn't give a [ __ ] and moved on
but her bodyguard behind her was
dying to laugh and gave me a little nod
as he passed
dude i don't know this sounds like all
victory here
the story i thought all right your
girlfriend has to have a bad reaction to
this
the story always gets a laugh with my
mates but the older i get the more i
think maybe i should have
just been polite i was at her show
after all so why be a dick that was me
in my 20s thinking i knew better than
the rest of the world the know-it-all
young englishman
such as life well you know what you also
[ __ ]
you know that about yourself it happens
guess what buddy you
are beautiful no matter what they say
um that's all right
everybody says do she thinks sometimes
everybody's a [ __ ]
sometimes i actually felt bad for her
man because that's
the way she was blowing through the line
though that's one of those things where
listen if you want to vacuum up the
extra money with the vip meet and greets
you got to [ __ ] either do it or don't
uh because the worst thing you do is
charge them the extra money for the vip
and then blow through the line and then
they actually feel like uh
like they got mugged uh what needed to
be said
hey billy pasty legs um i always listen
to your show and recently you've been
asking people to write in
with their stories about things they
should have said in the moment but they
didn't
well i have a story for you about
something actually saying
someone actually saying what they wanted
in the moment and it was brilliant
so this is called what needed to be said
in high school my friend and i
all had the same geography class i don't
know why these stories are so satisfying
both ways
because i have empathy for the people
that didn't say
what they wanted to say and have to
carry it and then i got this like all
right
for somebody sober doper
for the people who said um
what they wanted to say um i still love
that kid from the class well who the
[ __ ] asked you
it's that hot chick our teacher was a
holier than now feminist
the type that puts down men with every
chance they get while building up women
in the class at all times oh yeah right
in front of the guys
i took one of those classes about 30
years ago when a guy would ask any
question in that class she would treat
him like an absolute [ __ ]
but when a girl asked out loud is lava
like
really hot this is a grade 12 course the
teacher responded with what a great
question yes it
is yeah that's how it works
it's very easy to go from being
oppressed to being the oppressor
uh getting to the point one day she's
going
on an absolute tirade who knows what
happened to set her off like this on
this particular day she goes on and on
about how men are absolute creatures
that the world doesn't need anymore
because women can reproduce without them
now because of sperm bags
well you'd still need us to jerk off
into a cup and that more women graduate
high school and more women go to college
than men and more women
are starting to work in higher paid jobs
than men and she finishes this rant with
what do
what do me even have anymore oh you
[ __ ] idiot you didn't write it
correctly what do me
even have anymore well what do men even
have anymore you forgot the end
without missing a beat the quietest guy
in the back of room goes
sports all the guys in the class started
laughing so hard
she kicked most of us out of the
classroom but me and my friends still
bring that story up to this day when
we're together one of the funniest
moments in high school was a moment when
someone actually said
what they should they should have in
that moment
yeah and she acted like an absolute
child about it
yeah i mean
that is a thing that's why i make fun of
feminists i don't make fun of somebody
for being a feminist but just those loud
ones that's kind of
how they uh that's how that's how they
play the game
it's like uh people were sexist to me
and the solution
is for me to be the sexist i still this
this latest one
where they canceled somebody was so
[ __ ] ridiculous
it was like the person that got canceled
was obviously in the wrong and did
something wrong but the person that
he did it to they're not the ones that
canceled them
it was a bunch of bitter comics that
didn't get into a comedy festival
and took that moment to [ __ ] try to
to take this [ __ ] guy
out because not because they give a [ __ ]
about black people
it's because they hate that guy because
he didn't put him into a [ __ ]
a [ __ ] comedy festival
which in my ways it's like doesn't that
make you just as bad as he is
it'd be one thing if you actually gave a
[ __ ] and at some point
actually addressed what the guy did and
how that makes peop black people feel
nobody did
all they did was talk about what they
did what he did to them
and then i went to audition to the
festival and he said
this to me and that's
that's what you really cared about it's
just [ __ ] it's so [ __ ] stupid the
whole thing this is such a
stupid crazy [ __ ] time
and um i'm not wrong because you know
what's funny i i gotta tell you
something i went to this
uh this birthday party
all right i went to this birthday party
uh with my wife and it was at a gay bar
and there was a drag show
okay and i went in there and like
five or six different people came up to
me and i really love your comedy got a
picture blah blah blah blah
great time and everything so as he
walked out
my wife goes like wow man the gay crowd
in there well you know
that was really uh that was really cool
they really liked you right
and i said yeah do me a favor remember
that
remember that the next time these
[ __ ] idiots try to do that cancel
thing just remember that that is reality
and that that other [ __ ] is just people
just jockeying for this [ __ ]
narrative
or whatever because if i was what a lot
of people were saying to me
i am if i went in that bar i would have
been hearing it from everybody
instead it was the exact opposite and i
had a great [ __ ] time and so did
everybody else but that's not what
counts
that's what's not that's not what it
counts it's not what counts what's
counts with [ __ ]
i don't know what it whatever i would
love to know what the percentage of
people
are in these cancer culture things why
the [ __ ] isn't this goddamn plug working
so i can upload this [ __ ]
oh i know why because i'm still
recording [ __ ] stupid here
um yeah there's reality and then the
reality that cancer culture is trying to
present
as they abuse their power much like that
woman that was teaching feminism who is
so hardcore feminist that she literally
becomes a sexist
and thinks the solution is to then do to
men what was done to women
and then the reality is is like so the
only reason why you're not a
chauvinistic pig is because you were
born a woman
you're actually what you're fighting
that classic cliched thing so that's it
that's my little [ __ ] i'm off the stump
now go [ __ ] yourselves i'll check in on
you
on wednesday